hello and welcome to this ha step of the
day in today's video we're gonna talk
all about speeds and feeds will show you
the path that we take to reach starting
speed and feed values that we can trust
that will work with any tool and
material combination will be using
metric values in this video but have
made another video for those of you that
are running inches a few key concepts a
formula and we'll reach the RPM that our
program needs another quick calculation
and we'll establish our feed rate and
have you home in time for supper as we
jump into one of the coolest concepts in
CNC programming speeds and feeds I've
got a question for you are you ready if
our tractor is moving along at an
amazing one kilometer per hour
that's roughly 17 meters per minute
which tire is moving faster our small
front tire or our larger rear tires
everything for me begins with my setup
so check this out we're tightening up
those poles by hand
[Music]
that's it
pencils down answers I know it's kind of
a trick question it depends on what I
mean by faster if what I am asking is
how fast the tires are moving across the
surface of the ground where the rubber
meets the road then both tires are
traveling at the exact same speed 17
surface meters per minute see both tires
travel the same distance where it
matters along the tires edge now if
we're talking about revolutions per
minute rpms
then that's a different story while both
tires cover the same amount of ground
the smaller tire had to make more
revolutions per minute to get there if
we want to calculate how much ground a
tire will cover with each revolution
then we'll need to come up with some
kind of ratio between a tires diameter
and its circumference well it turns out
someone has already figured this out for
us and they've even given this ratio a
name pi the ratio between a circles
diameter and its circumference is pi so
no matter what diameter our tire is the
distance around the outside of that tire
where the rubber meets the road is
always 3.14 times greater this tire at
100 millimeter diameter has a
circumference of 314 millimeters 100
times pi is 314 now this tire has a
diameter of 1 meter and a circumference
of 3.14 meters 1 times pi equals 3.14
okay back it up get out of it
if we were to run our tires too fast too
many surface meters per minute they
would overheat blister and fail our end
Mills work in the same way there's a
limit a maximum cutting speed that a
specific tool can go on a specific
material any faster and it begins to
overheat
in machinist talk if we're talking about
speeds like speeds and feeds we can be
talking about one of two different
things
we're either talking about cutting speed
or spindle speeds our cutting speed BC
is our surface meters per minute the
speed our tool is turning at where the
rubber meets the road where it where the
tool meets the part and our spindle
speed is simply our revolutions per
minute our rpm we'll get our tools
cutting speed in meters per minute right
from our tool catalogs but the control
the Hosmer she it needs an RPM value a
spindle speed that's our s code to get
from here to here we're going to use a
formula and that formula is gonna make
use of pi and our tools diameter to
convert our meters per minute into an
RPM value a spindle speed now once we've
got that rpm value we can calculate our
feed rates speeds and feeds here is our
formula to calculate our RPM now I'm
gonna start using some some symbols some
notation because those are the symbols
being used by all of the tool suppliers
now and you'll need to recognize them RP
M equals cutting speed times 1000 all
divided by our diameter times pi n is
our rpm revolutions per minute that's
the S code in our program what we're
trying to solve for VC is our cutting
speed our surface meters per minute D or
sometimes DC or d1 depending on the
catalog is our tool diameter in
millimeters the 1000 in this formula is
there to convert our meters per minute
into millimeters per minute this formula
works fantastic but we're going to
simplify it a bit using algebra we're
going to divide the 1000 by PI 1000
divided by pi is about 318
we're gonna go ahead and use this
simplified formula for the rest of the
video before we open up our catalog and
get our cutting speed before the tractor
even leaves the barn we need to know
exactly what cutting tool we're gonna
use and we need to know exactly what
material we are going to be cutting now
in the good old days all we really
needed to know was whether our mo was
high speed steel carbide PCD or cbn
those days are gone
today's tools have coatings on them that
might double their allowable cutting
speeds so we really need to know what
tool we are working with otherwise we'll
have to use really generic values which
are pretty wimpy with our exact tool
number in hand we can go to our our tool
catalog we can download the manual for
any tool manufacturer in PDF form once
that catalog is opened up we're gonna
search for the material group section
that's going to tell us what material
group our exact material falls into our
materials are color coded
P is for Steel's Emma's for stainless
steels k is for cast irons and is for
non-ferrous metals without iron in them
like aluminum or magnesium S is for our
super alloys materials like titanium and
H is for hard cast irons or hardened
steels I am working with a 4140 steel at
least that's what we call it here in the
United States if you're in Europe and
you're using en names and numbers this
might be called 42 CR mo 4 if you're in
Japan you'll call it something different
but no matter where you are in the world
this material is gonna find itself in
the P I so material class now the number
that follows our color coded iso letter
changes between manufacturers so be
careful here kena mental calls this
material a P for Niagara and C Co may
call it a p5 Sandvik classifies it as a
P 2.1
while Iskar and Whittier might call it a
p6 or a p7 same material different tool
vendor now it's important that we get
this right if you don't choose the right
material group you are gonna burn up
your tools titanium has a different
machine ability than mild steel if you
try running a drill or an end mill in
titanium at cutting speeds meant for
mild steel you are gonna melt that tool
it will overheat and fail so if you
can't find what material group your
stock should be in then give your
tooling representative a call they would
love to hear from you
how many tooling reps out there would
love to hear from one of our viewers and
talk tools yeah that's what I thought
from the section of the manual for our
exact tool under the row that lists our
material group p5 in our case we're
gonna find our cutting speed our VC our
meters per minute if your catalog gives
you a range of values there then you'll
make your choice based on the length of
your tool how strong your setup is and
how aggressive we tend to cut in general
the more ridge of the setup the faster
we can go with our cutting speeds but
remember tools tend to last longer have
better tool life at lower cutting speeds
for my tool and material we're gonna use
a cutting speed of 100 that's 100 meters
for a minute I'm using a 20 millimeter
end mill so we'll drop in 20 there and
after a little bit of math we come up
with an RPM value of 1592 so our s code
back in our program is going to be s 1 5
9 2 we now have a cutting speed and RPM
value that we can use without our tool
exactly we now know how fast to spin our
tool our speed the control now needs our
table feed our F coat feed rate the feed
rate is how far the tool will try
in one minute in millimeters along the
tools centerline here is our feed rate
formula for n mils we've got our table
feed equals our feed per tooth times the
number of teeth times our rpm so what's
a tooth this is a tooth it's just a
cutting edge along the outside of a tool
an insert is also a tooth it's for most
tools the number of teeth matches the
number of flutes this tool has three
flutes three teeth this tools got six
teeth and this one's got four we want
our tool to take a very specific size
bite with each tooth this is our feed
for two in millimeters just like our
cutting speed the book or PDF will give
us that feed per tooth value the catalog
says that for my tool material and type
of tool path point zero eight
millimeters per tooth is a good starting
range 0.08 our feed per tooth times for
our number of teeth times 1592 our rpm
will give us our millimeters per minute
feed rate f50 nine point four four again
this is how far the center line of our
tool will move along its programmed path
in millimeters each and every minute
some manuals will just give out a single
feed rate for all cutting conditions but
most will give us at least two
possibilities one for slotting and one
for side milling our AE is our width of
cut that's our step over
that's our radial depth of cut and our
AP is our axial depth of cut how deep
the tool is moving in the z axis most
times if you're slotting your bite is
going to be about 25% less than if
you're just side milling with the
popularity of optimized tool paths like
dynamic adaptive volume mill type high
speed machining tool paths the
two manufacturers are getting more and
more specific with their speed and feed
recommendations so you'll often see
charts like the one we'll show you here
listing all kinds of different tool
paths you'll choose one and then match
your speed and feed to the path that
you're using now if you are dealing with
drills and not end mills our feed rate
might be listed in our catalogues as a
feed per revolution and not a feed per
tooth we just multiply the millimeters
per revolution chip load from the book
times our RPM to get our feed rate in
millimeters per minute now watch out for
and know the difference between
millimeters per tooth FZ which we
typically use for milling tools and
millimeters per revolution F n which we
often use for drills here is a completed
legend and the formulas we typically use
for calculating our speeds and feeds
we've got our cutting speed formulas
spindle speeds we've got our feed rate
formulas for both n mills and drills and
we've got all of the notations all the
symbols that you're gonna see over and
over again in your tool catalogs with
all of that said there's a big shift
happening with tooling catalogs in
general a lot of these tooling catalogs
are just giving us our feed rate and rpm
values no formulas needed you may open
up your manual and finally you don't
have to do any math at all in the past
we used to have to rely on slide rules
to calculate our RPM and feed rate
I still like these I think they're great
but today we're more likely to use an
app on our phone or a piece of software
on our computer or the speeds and feeds
calculator right on the haas control on
machines with next-gen controls you can
reach the million calculator by pressing
current commands and navigating to the
milling tab we've made some videos that
help you calculate those those tapping
feed rates will link to those in the
description well that's it let's go home
you
call your tooling rep in the morning
well thanks for letting us be a part of
your success and for watching this ha
step of the day
[Music]